please welcome
meredith and jacob bertrand
[Applause]
thank you thank you
oh my god
i love you guys so much thank you thank
you my daughters and i have seen every
second of cobra kai thank you thank you
and we've seen a ton of we've seen a ton
of yours no we were talking about
we're super excited to be here so thank
you guys for having us you're gonna play
blue beetle
and you have been cast in this very
important role thank you thank you i
appreciate that and you've spoken so
eloquently about representation and
stepping into this great humility
representation like you said is
is is something that's of utmost
importance to me and obviously this is a
big opportunity but it's only to open
more doors for other people hopefully
you know that's that's the goal that's
always the goal it's that's what it's
been since the beginning and and this is
hopefully just another stepping stone
jacob i mean
we love hawk so much
you don't have the mohawk right now when
did you have to shave it off and how was
it
just recently uh it was sad you know it
adds like
nine inches to my height and it makes me
feel like fix five you know so i walk
around you know with that confidence but
yeah i was a little bummed but you know
i liked rocking the bus it wasn't uh it
wasn't too horrible i have to say what
an incredible actor you are in the sense
that oh thank you the fact that you're
not like hawk is such a testament to how
good you are because
hawk is a very complicated character
yeah well i mean i don't know i mean i
hope i'm not like that guy definitely
was definitely a bully for a long time
whenever it's 50 50 whenever i meet
people they're like wow i love logs my
favorite character this is so great but
sometimes we go i hate you you are
atrocious this is
i like meeting you but this is not i
don't like you you play him so well
because he is not one note so bravo i
love you talk so much
and thank you i love
watching you fight i love the scene one
of my favorite scenes in cobra kai i've
heard
might be
your favorite scene so i'm so excited
let's see is it the one where you're
talking to william
zabka in the
restaurant
yes yes yes yes that is one of my
favorite scenes and honestly get in the
film with billy if you haven't had the
chance to meet him he is i haven't he is
the guy to meet i mean
i mean we i like i were
the from day one he was so welcoming and
so appreciative of this opportunity to
really breathe in some new life to this
character that for so many years people
had hated you know and exactly and you
know uh you know getting to
turn a new leaf and kind of bring a
whole new
vision to this story that no one had
really even known about is is super
awesome and just to get a play a part in
that is
phenomenal but that guy is he couldn't
you know speaking of guys who are no
nothing like their characters that guy
is the sweetest guy in the world and and
that scene and honestly all the kind of
more emotional scenes are my favorite
carrie underwood is in season four this
is true yeah yeah yeah i haven't gotten
there yet i'm freaking out yeah she's
going okay so we won't slowly spoil it
okay she does make an appearance she
plays herself okay as carrie underwood
you gotta play yourself there's no way
that she was she was playing anyone else
and and she makes a she she does a bit
of a performance it was super fun
and uh jacob actually came up with a fun
idea when she was
on set he was like i think it'd be fun
if we took a picture with her
under wood so that we'd be carrying
carrie underwood under wood
and when she game oh she's kidding yes
so it's amazing
i first told our producers like hey i
have this idea what do you guys think
and all three of them were like this is
the dumbest idea i've ever heard of do
not ask her this and i told show that he
was like oh bro i'll just ask i'll just
ask and i won't say anything to them i
was like okay good luck like
hopefully it works i read that you had a
crush on rihanna is that true oh snap no
uh yes i did for the longest time i had
publicized that i
did have a liking for for rihanna
obviously she is unavailable now so
that is uh not gonna happen and but
yeah she seems like a sweet woman and
you guys are roommates which i loved
that like the first year or like you
were like always at each other's places
and then you're like wait no next year
let's just be in the same place we'll
save money and we're always up playing
video games until the dawn hours anyway
wait jacob do you have a current crush
uh i don't know
it depends usually i'm just hanging out
with sholo all the time i will say i do
have a girlfriend right now i was gonna
say and i actually read that you have a
girlfriend so that is your crush
[Music]